okay
welcome to the ddps seminar today before
we
introduce today's speaker uh let's go
over some rules and logistics
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk unless you have questions so
that our speaker can talk
without unnecessary interruptions if you
have clarification
questions you are welcome to amuse
yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please your chat room to post
your questions so that we can
address them in q a session at the end
second no classified discussion is
allowed here so watch out
finally the talk today will be recorded
and
uploaded in our youtube channel
all right that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker
it is an uh honor to host today's
speaker
priya dante who is a phd student in
computer science and
public policy at carnegie mellon
university
and the u.s department of energy
computational science graduate fellow
she is also a co-founder and
chair of climate change a.i
an initial initiative to capitalize
impactful work in climate change and
machine learning
our work lies at the intersection of
electric power systems and climate
change
mitigation specifically her research
explores
ways to incorporate domain knowledge
such as power system physics
into machine learning models today priya
will present
incorporating power system physics into
deep learning they are implicit layers
which is very interesting topic so
please enjoy
a wonderful talk now without further ado
let me pass the button
to priya alright thanks yongsu for the
kind introduction and for the invitation
today um
so yeah as you mentioned today i'll be
talking about some work basically trying
to incorporate
physics and hard constraints from the
electric power system into deep learning
methods using a tool called implicit
layers
if you have any questions during the the
talk as young as you mentioned please
feel free to
yourself and ask i'll also be monitoring
the chat during the talk so feel free to
just drop your questions in there and
i'll get to them as we go
so it's probably no news to a lot of
people that deep learning is often
referred to as a black box
so these two representations on the
slide are for instance very popular
representations that are often discussed
so one of which is a literal black box
where we have some inputs and we produce
some outputs
and another one where maybe we open up
the the box a little bit
and write down these little traffic
light looking thingies that
fundamentally still then map from inputs
to outputs
and so during this talk i want to
propose a very specific
view of deep learning that then will
kind of frame the way in which
um i kind of introduced this topic of
implicit layers
so deep learning fundamentally
can be viewed as differentiable function
composition
so the um composition of different
functions that can be
through which we can take derivatives so
for example kind of looking at this
little traffic light diagram on on the
slide
you can think of each of these little
traffic lights as a function
each of these functions has some
parameters associated with it
and overall we want to try to adjust
these parameters usually using a
procedure called back propagation
to try to minimize some notion of error
or loss
so the basic idea here is that every
single component
of this neural network so every single
function that we are composing together
within this neural network
needs to be differentiable
that then kind of potentially gives a
slightly different view
of what a deep learning layer is so
often when we talk about deep learning
layers we talk about them in terms of
okay it's some
activation function you know there's a
relu in this layer there's a sigmoid in
this layer
but really a deep learning layer can be
thought of as a function
with certain kinds of attributes so
these attributes are one
the ability to map from inputs to
outputs this is the forward procedure
the ability to compute gradients of the
outputs of that layer or the loss of the
overall network
with respect to the inputs or function
parameters so some backwards procedure
and ideally though this is not necessary
ideally these are
not too too expensive to compute that
you can so you can actually kind of plug
them into a deep network at scale
and so in general the basic idea is that
rather than viewing a neural network
architecture as again
some kind of black box that we can't
modify or something that we choose
without principle
we can actually create and insert custom
layers
into neural networks that allow us to
express functions or relationships that
we think are actually rather important
for the domain that we might be trying
to work in
and so sort of one kind of custom layer
that i'd like to put forth
is sort of this general class of layers
called implicit layers
so to talk about implicit layers i'll
first talk about something that is not
an implicit layer which is a
quote-unquote explicit layer so the idea
is that we're often used to dealing with
deep network layers
that are characterized by some kind of
explicit function
some function where we can directly
write down a mapping between some inputs
x
and the layer outputs z and in general
it's fairly
easy to differentiate through these
various kinds of layers
in particular because we have some you
know very nice explicit function that we
can find the derivative with respect to
but um we can also create layers that
are characterized by
implicit functions so an implicit
function is a function where you don't
necessarily have an explicit mapping
between the input the outputs but where
you have some relationship like that one
on the slide
um that that basically characterizes
this relationship between inputs and
outputs
and the basic idea is that if you kind
of
you if you take the derivative through
this kind of um
through this the fixed point of this um
implicit function or the equilibrium
condition of this implicit function
and write out the chain rule and so
forth then you get some
way um some kind of relationship that
you can write out to actually get the
derivative through this layer
so this is sort of a whirlwind overview
of the kind of concept
concept of implicit layers and for those
who are um kind of interested in this
i would encourage you to check out the
tutorial that's linked at the bottom
left of the slide
but the basic idea here is that we can
figure out a way
to embed a relatively rich set of
functions that can be represented
by implicit layers into neural networks
because we can figure out how to take
derivatives through these layers
and implicit layers have sort of taken
many many different forms in the
literature
so for example um many of you have
likely seen
neural ordinary differential equations
or neural odes
but there have also been layers that
encode for example rigid body physics
layers that basically encode infinite
quote unquote infinite width sequence
models
and also layers that encode optimization
problems in this case specifically
convex
optimization problems so kind of this
little
this this very small guest shift in the
way we think about neural network layers
can actually create
can kind of yield a very rich set of
functions that we can actually embed
into neural networks
so that's sort of the general idea of
implicit layers
and i kind of want to show the the power
of these implicit layers
um and the kind of the different kinds
of things that you can use them to do
um in the context of my own work and so
um
i will sort of try to give an example of
how you would build such an implicit
layer for
power system optimization and to try to
show basically how you would use this
layer for different kinds of
applications
so first a little bit of background on
power systems optimization
so an electric power system
basically the way um in which of course
you get
electricity delivered to your house for
example um
managing an electric power system is
actually a very complex endeavor
so specifically you have you know some
amount of electricity that's being
produced
on the electric grid at any given time
from um fossil fuel sources like coal
and natural gas
but also from um renewable energy like
you know
wind solar etc and then you also have
some amount of energy that is being
consumed
on the electric power grid at any moment
so both due to
actual demand that we have our lights
our heating and cooling systems etc and
then also due to resisted
resistive losses that occur sort of as
power is transmitted throughout the grid
and the kind of challenge with balancing
electric power systems is that the
amount of power
supplied into the power grid has to
equal the amount of power consumed
at every single moment and this can be
really challenging when there's
uncertainty in how much power can
is being consumed at any time people's
demand for example changes from moment
to moment
and also how much power is being
produced due to maybe changes in the
weather
uncertainty and renewable uncertainty
and sort of cloud cover that might
change the amount of solar power
production for example
and so the way that this kind of
constraint of you know electricity
supply
has to equal electricity demand is is
often kind of
um addressed in power systems is through
the use of a
optimization problem called ac optimal
power flow which is this problem on the
slide
the basic idea of ac optimal power flow
is
that we want to minimize some objective
on the power grid
usually the costs of power production
and i just want to point out that this
sort of variable we're optimizing over
which contains many different quantities
um in
many different power system quantities
that we need to solve for includes the
amount of power that is produced at each
power generator but
basically the optimization objective
here is to minimize the cost
of power production we want to do this
subject to
various linear constraints that occur on
the power system
things even as simple as converting
between different quantities
various linear inequality constraints
that encode things like
limits on the outputs of various devices
so for example a particular power
generator might have a maximum or
minimum amount of power that it can
produce
and then finally this last constraint
which is a power flow constraint which
basically enforces basically that the
the amount of power going
into every node is equivalent to the
amount of power coming out
from every node and this particular
constraint is really nasty
it's non-convex and as a result this
optimization problem overall
is is slow to solve so there's a lot of
work that tries to address how to
solve this problem more quickly for
example that's not necessarily the focus
of this work but generally this problem
of ac optimal power flow there's a lot
of research on how to solve it more
quickly
and then one additional thing i'll note
is that the kind of
amount of money you would pay for for
power the power price at a given node is
actually a dual variable on
on this power flow constraint so if that
means something to you
awesome and if it doesn't don't worry
about it just something kind of
interesting i wanted to point out
so how do we actually solve the ac
optimal power flow problem
and how do we turn it into a neural
network layer
so the basic idea for solving ac optimal
power flow
a forward procedure there are many
different ways you would you could solve
this problem but i'm just going to pose
one here so first
in general um in in a lot of these cases
we assume
that the function of
the cost of power production
is basically a quadratic function of
power production
and we also basically um
say okay this overall problem is
actually kind of hard to solve because
of this kind of non-linear power flow
constraint
let's linearize this constraint so
imagine that we have some current
guess for the the outputs of the
optimization problem let's linearize it
around that guess
and then solve the problem
and the idea is that we can solve this
via sequential quadratic programming so
basically
we given this quadratic objective and
this linearized constraint
we can solve this particular problem we
can come up with some new guess
for the solution we can re-linearize
our constraint around this new guess and
so on and so forth we do this over and
over again
until the solution converges
now to actually incorporate acopf into a
neural network we have to differentiate
through it
and the basic idea here is that
the last quadratic program that we saw
this last convex quadratic program that
we solve
um is differentiable and the way in
which you differentiate through it
is you write down something called the
kkt conditions of this problem
so basically the conditions written on
the slide that characterize the um
the um optimal solutions of that
particular problem
we can then and i know this is a lot of
ugly math on the slide so the details
aren't important here but the
at a high level we basically can
implicitly differentiate through these
kkt
conditions basically take the derivative
through these various kkt conditions
and then as a result um we basically
write down
this linear system that allows us to
solve for these gradients
dz star d theta etc that we actually
need to solve for
so again the sort of details on this
particular slide aren't super important
but at a high level
we are basically taking this last
quadratic program
that we solved in order to to to solve a
copf to solve ac optimal power flow
we're writing down the optimality
conditions of that particular
optimization problem
and then we're taking derivatives
through those optimality conditions
so before i move on to kind of specific
applications that this kind of ac
optimal power flow layer can be used for
are there any questions um either
clarifying questions or anything else
that
anyone would like to ask first
okay so i will continue
so there are a number of different
applications for which this kind of
paradigm can be used so the first is
decision driven forecasting
so specifically one application in the
context of
electric power systems is demand
forecasting so as i mentioned before
electricity demand is really um
is potentially very variable and this is
really important to get a handle on in
order to balance electric power systems
and so in general we tend to want to
predict future electricity demand maybe
with some notion of uncertainty
based on past electricity demand as well
as other factors such as weather
and time and we want to learn a neural
network model
in this case i'm going to call that h
sub theta that basically represents this
relationship between our features
and the predictions of future demand
and in general what tends to be done
is that the the objective tends to be to
try to create a neural network model
that makes predictions of future demand
that are as accurate as possible so
this could be represented by for example
the equation on the slide where
for some inputs x the and some current
estimate of our parameters theta
our estimated future demand is given by
the output of our function on those
inputs so h sub theta of
x and then the true future demand is
is y and this loss function would be
something like the root mean squared
error or other measure of accuracy
of the predictions so this is generally
what we would do
basically try to optimize for the
accuracy
of the predictions and i would argue
that this
is actually a kind of flawed notion
so in particular accuracy doesn't always
represent the thing that we want to
optimize
in order to improve the quality of
decisions on the power grid
so to give an example there if we let's
say
have a demand forecasting model that
predicts
x units of power consumption
in the next two hours now
let's or that or rather sorry x units of
power consumption in the next few hours
is the actual correct answer
if we have one model that predicts that
the power consumption will be x
plus 10 and another model that
predicts x minus 10 so one that over
predicts by 10 and one that under pricks
by 10
the accuracy of these two models would
be the same
but these models actually would have
very different
implications for power system operation
so for example if i over predict
electricity demand by 10 units
that might cause a power system operator
to over procure
electricity and some of that electricity
would then need to be wasted which would
um
you know have bad implications for for
the cost of operation but
not necessarily be the worst thing in
the world
that said if one were to under predict
demand by 10 units
then an electricity system operate
operator may then
under procure power and then need to
scramble at the last minute
to make up that power generation so
while from an accuracy perspective an
under prediction and an overprediction
of 10 units may be similar
from a actual decision-making
perspective they're not
and so a question can then be
how do we actually incorporate knowledge
about the decision making procedure
into our forecasting model in order to
then make sure that our model
isn't making fatal mistakes that are
really very bad for the application
and so the way we can think about this
is instead of just thinking about
well what are our inputs and what is our
prediction of future demand
we can also think about if i make
a prediction of future demand then
what will the electricity generation
schedule be
that is made on the basis of that
prediction so in other words if i make a
prediction
what is the decision going to be that is
made on the basis of my prediction
and then if i can understand basically
how good that decision
is what the cost of that decision is
then i can basically um encode that
information
into my model and train a model that is
cognizant of the quality of the decision
made on its basis
so instead of basically trying to
optimize the accuracy of a given model
which is again the equation now on the
on the bottom of the slide
we instead want to minimize the cost of
the generation schedule that is made on
the basis of our predictions
when it acts upon actual electricity
demand
so here when we have here we have x
again our inputs
theta is the parameters of our neural
network model
and the idea is that we have a neural
network model with some parameters when
it's given inputs it will create some
prediction
and we care about what is the decision z
star
that is made on the basis of our
prediction
and then what we want to do is minimize
the cost
of that decision against the true power
demand that we observe in the future
so that is basically this decision
driven forecasting paradigm
and so how does this tie into the idea
of implicit layers
so the idea is that you would generally
construct a neural network model to
predict electricity demand
something like this this generic neural
network i mentioned i have on the slide
where you have some inputs
x the output is y hat so your prediction
of demand
and then you have some parameters theta
the idea here what we do here is we
actually
given the demand prediction y
hat that comes out of our model we run
it through
a power system optimization model ac
optimal power flow or economic dispatch
or something else like that
and then we get some decision
z star that is made on the basis of our
prediction
and then we can compute the cost of that
decision
against the true power demand that we
see
and back propagate this cost throughout
the entire network sort of update all of
the parameters of the network on this
basis
and then basically what this means is
that the
parameters of our demand forecasting
network are being updated in a way
that is cognizant of the overall system
cost that we're actually trying to to
minimize
and the kind of upshot here is that this
decision-driven approach or this kind of
approach can in general dramatically
reduce the cost of scheduling power on
the electric grid
so to show that first i want to show the
performance of two different models so
the
kind of green solid line is our network
and the red dashed line is a network
that is trying to optimize
just for accuracy we are the setting
we're looking at is where at the
beginning of the day you're predicting
electricity demand 24 hours out and then
the y
so those are the x-axis is the hour of
the day for which we're making the
prediction
and the y-axis here is the root mean
squared error
of the prediction so
what this particular plot shows is that
the kind of accuracy optimizing model
the model that we're comparing against
is actually more accurate has a lower
root mean squared
error than our model and that makes
sense it's optimizing
for accuracy
on the other hand when we look at
performance
not in terms of just the pure accuracy
of the model
but when we look at basically how good a
decision did it allow us to make so here
the y-axis is now the overall cost of
scheduling the power system
what we see is that the cost associated
with our model
is actually much much lower so
even though our model is less accurate
on some in some sense it is it is
worse in terms of a standard metric like
accuracy that we would usually use
it is actually better in terms of
enabling power system operators to make
decisions regarding how they should
actually schedule
power in a way that dramatically reduces
costs and in this case the
in our in our simulated setting the
improvement in in generator scheduling
costs was actually around 40
hi priya can i interrupt to ask a
question yes please um
so if i understand this correctly um
looking at the figure on the right over
the first eight hours
the task loss is essentially the same
but then is there some threshold over
which
your the accuracy is there's just a
divergence right at about the 10 hour
mark
which is surprising looking at the rmse
so i'd be interesting to see what the
is that a threshold effect we're over a
certain at loss
your task loss blows up
yeah that's a great question so what is
actually happening here
is that um there are constraints that
basically
ramping constraints that basically
determine based on how much power i
decided to produce from a particular
generator
in a particular hour this is the amount
of power i can produce in the next hour
which cannot be kind of too much more or
too much less than what it was producing
in the previous hour so there's very
these various kinds of ramping
constraints that occur
and so what i think is basically
happening under the hood here
is that initially when the accuracy is
good there are many different things you
can do in terms of actually you know how
you actually schedule power
and so forth but then those early
decisions that you make kind of
affect what later decisions you can make
in terms of scheduling power
um and and basically around that uh
eight nine hour mark that's basically
where the kinds of mistakes that the
root mean squared error model is making
have basically
caused the generator scheduling to go
into a state where it's not able to sort
of recover or compensate for
for various kinds of um i guess like
lack of look-ahead that it had before
um i don't know if that answers your
question yeah that makes perfect sense
thank you
okay so brenda asks
slide 18 which model is more
transferable though did you try
transferring this model to another time
period and see which is more
generalizable
so that's a great question um and i
guess two
two comments on that basis so this is
actually over
many different 24-hour periods so what
you're seeing is sort of an
average over both many different data
points and also many different
replicas of the same experiment but the
general question i think still holds if
you're training a task based model
will it really generalize to other
settings and
the answer here is is yes and no so the
the reason you would train a task-based
model is because you want it to perform
very well
on a on a particular on a particular
task that said it's not necessarily a
ton of effort to
to create a task-based model for a
particular task so in this experiment
what we actually did
is we pre-trained our model with with
less data because we we had some holdout
data but basically we pre-trained a
um accuracy optimizing model a root mean
squared error optimizing model
and then sort of took that model and
trained it a few more steps
in order to tune it towards the task
loss and so it is that we started with a
base model that is in some sense kind of
general but we were able to optimize it
fairly quickly
for our particular task at hand
um i have one quick question maybe you
already mentioned it but can you just
define
task loss really quickly because like um
rmse is like kind of very clear to
everyone like it predicted something
and you know that's the error but uh
what exactly is
task loss like mathematically and then
also
practically yeah so past class is this
sort and thank you for i didn't clarify
that well so um it's the sort of
optimization objective that i've written
here which is the kind of power
or the kind of cost of creating this
kind of electric
electricity generation schedule um when
it acts upon a particular demand profile
um and i haven't defined this on the
slide here but this this depends on the
particular
the particular task of course and so in
in this case what it actually represents
is um there's a particular um
cost for basically um oversupplying
electricity compared to the actual
amount of demand
and there's another cost for
under-supplying electricity at any given
moment
with respect to the actual demand and
these have different weights on them so
the cost of oversupplying is in some
sense
less weighted than the cost of
under-supplying because of
under-supplying it is worse and so
um this task loss is for kind of a
honestly like kind of arbitrary setting
of weights that we had created to
um just to to heuristically give a sense
of what
how bad or good these things are in
relation to
each other but um you would want to in
some sense tune those various weights
based on the actual realities of the
system
i see so um in another system where
maybe
um you know the over production is
uh you know has a different weight than
the under
production um like maybe it's not energy
related but
i don't know manufacturing food or
something like that
um then those weights would change and
so the
task loss definition would also change
right
yeah and then go ahead
oh and then the the and then you would
train your model
on that definition of task loss as
opposed to a different definition of
task loss so the idea is here that you
really are
trying to fit or quote unquote over fit
to the particular domain you care about
um by actually incorporating that actual
loss function in
i see okay and if you had a different
definition of task loss even for this
same problem that would kind of affect
what these two curves look like
is that correct absolutely and this is
kind of true for any metric right
like accuracy any loss function really
you're always
um optimizing your your model for
some metric and if the metric shifts out
from under you then your model is going
to perform differently
and so sort of one kind of thematic
takeaway of this work is really
understand what your metric is don't
necessarily kind of go for the default
metric of for example accuracy if that's
not actually what you care about in your
system
um and sort of understand that kind of
no loss function is really
truly agnostic in the way that we kind
of think it is
right okay but so for this uh definition
of task loss
that's kind of the the um appropriate
one for this energy problem
absolutely okay got it thank you yeah no
thank you that's a great question
okay so jerome mentions one of the
issues that i wonder about is the
requirement for differentiability
there are a lot of decisions and those
are usually and those are usually the
most important ones that involve
discrete points so turn on
or buy a new generator that involve you
know huge discrete costs etc
so jerome that's absolutely a great
question so in this case we're
definitely just looking at the ac
optimal power flow settings so kind of
like instantaneous scheduling decisions
we're not looking at the kind of unit
commitment
setting that said there actually has
been
some amount of work though not
necessarily yet applied to power systems
that has tried to provide the ability to
differentiate through combinatorial
optimization problems or discrete
optimization problems of different forms
and i think that would be really
actually a quite important area of
future work in the context of power
systems if we really want to bring for
example unit commitment decisions into
deep learning models
okay and so brenda asks
the um formulation is deterministic
how are you addressing uncertainties so
it's a really great question here so
what we're doing is that when we um
kind of create the task loss so the task
loss
the actual actual task loss is an
expectation
of this kind of overproduction under
production cost
um over um the the actual demand that we
see but the demand is of course
stochastic and so what we actually do
when we're running the deep network
model is we make an assumption
that the um the
demand function is going to be normally
distributed
um and so we then kind of rewrite
analytically that expectation in terms
of the mean
and standard deviation of um the the
demand function and
our network predicts the mean and
standard deviation um
so there is actually even though the
kind of high level pitch has been you
know train your neural network on the
actual task loss that will be happening
in the real world we did make an
assumption and
during training we did say okay we're
actually going to make a gaussian
assumption here
even though during test time that's not
necessarily true um
but even with that basically it turns
out that that assumption of assuming
that the future demand is is gaussian
is a kind of less harmful assumption
than sort of the accuracy one is kind of
what the
um the result is showing here but we did
have to find a way to do this
analytically basically
okay priya uh we are getting many
questions but i i
maybe move on for now and then uh
address that in q a
um yeah that sounds good to me and i
hear you more about
what you've prepared there we go all
right thank you
and onwards i go thanks for everyone for
the great questions
all right so application two
is addressing the vulnerability of power
grid data
so in electric power systems there a lot
of entities sort of face
various challenges around whether they
should make certain power system data
private or public so for instance
releasing releasing information about
electricity
bids how much different power generators
or market players are bidding into an
electricity market
may allow some players to exert market
power to basically distort the outcomes
of the market on the basis of that
information
and releasing other information stuff
like the topology of the power grid
could lead to cyber security risks on
the other hand
there are actually lots of reasons that
we want to make data public
so for instance many power system
operators publish power prices to
promote market transparency
or the u.s environmental protection
agency
publishes the power generation and
emissions associated with
large fossil fuel generators at every
hour in order to facilitate emissions
monitoring
so the idea is yes there's a lot of data
that's public and then there's a lot of
data that's intentionally kept
private and a question is is there
potentially actually leakage between
these two things is there not actually
as big a separation between private and
public data as we think there is
and so the question we ask in in this
piece of work is basically can unknown
or private information on the power grid
be reverse engineered from information
that is already available
so in the us context we can think about
things like
power in generator power injections and
locational power
prices on the power grid as being
available and things like
electricity bids and the structure of
the power grid
um or the admittance matrix for those
who are familiar with power systems
terminology
as being unknown and yet we do
kind of know the relationship between
these known and unknown quantities
at a high level they are described by
power system optimization decisions um
which i will kind of simplify to to
being ac optimal power flow in this case
and so we can write down sort of an
attempt to
to try to guess the unknown information
from the known information
as this problem of inverse optimal power
flow
the basic idea is that if we have some
guesses for the bidding
bidding parameters so that's c hat and
for the power grid structure that's y
hat and we put those into an ac optimal
power flow model along with information
about power demands
then that ac optimal power flow model
will give us an estimate
of what the power generation and the
locational prices would
be if our estimates of these unknown
parameters are
are correct and then if we can basically
figure out well what input parameters
what private parameters can i choose
that actually leave the outputs of my
acopf model
to be close to the real values of power
generation and power prices that i
observe
then it is possible they're not
necessarily guaranteed but it is
possible that i have basically guessed
the values of these private parameters
properly
and so with any optimization problem for
those who work in optimization
it's always really easy to write it down
it's it's often very hard to solve the
problem
and so the way we solve this problem is
actually through adjoint
methods or you can again think of this
as sort of a differentiable layer that
we use in order to solve this problem
so the basic idea is that we can kind of
write our parameter
identification model down like this
where we have some
kind of ac optimal power flow
differentiable object
layer whatever you want to call it it's
not really in a deep network here but
some kind of differentiable ac optimal
powerful
object you then have some parameters
here your kind of guesses of your
bidding curve
bidding costs and then also of the grid
structure
and then you put those into the ac
optimum power flow
you kind of get out a guess for power
generation and power prices
you compute some cost how close is that
to the actual quantities i see on the
grid
and then you update your guesses the
parameters of the ac optimal power flow
layer via back propagation
so we initially test this out
on a very small and simulated test case
just sort of
some initial investigation so it's a 14
bus test case
with around 200 data points that are
simulated on this grid
and what we find at a high level is that
the with very small amounts of data so
the number of data points we actually
use in different experiments on the
x-axis
we are actually able to recover the
bidding parameters the costs of
different generators
um with very few data points so here we
have each generator generator one two
and three or eight
i guess in a different plot um and then
the y-axis as the squared error
um and you can sort of see that the
squared error of our estimate sort of
drops to zero with with
way fewer than ten data points
on the other hand guessing the power
grid structure is harder
um these plots are a little strange to
read but the y-axis of each of these
plots is the squared error of our
parameter estimate of a particular grid
parameter um and the x-axis here is sort
of the
um the uh error over our kind of the
output of our acopf
model um and so you can think of the
kind of being
left on the x-axis here means we're at
the beginning of our algorithm
and being all the way right on this
x-axis here means we sort of run our
algorithm to convergence
and the basic idea is that you would
want to end up at this zero
zero point on the right you want when
our algorithm has stopped
for our estimate of the parameter to be
correct and we find for grid structure
that this is
sometimes true and sometimes not
sometimes we get to this nice zero zero
point like for the solid blue line
where we have a parameter that we were
able to guess um
but then sometimes we end up with this
orange dashed line
which basically says we ended up with
the wrong value for our particular
parameter
and so um the idea here is that guessing
the grid structure is potentially harder
potentially because also there are
some parameters that don't necessarily
affect the outcome of the power system
optimization that often
okay so one last application before i
wrap it up and get to the questions
is um an application to provably robust
power system
control
so the basic idea here is that deep
reinforcement learning
has started to you know become a very
popular um method especially in kind of
it has found a lot of success success in
gaming domains like
atari dota go all of these kind of
things
and the reason it's been so successful
is that
it can learn very expressive um policies
very expressive controllers
and it generally does this in order to
it generally does this by
exploring some system trying out various
things
optimizing its behavior based on that
it's deep rl is in some ways an
opposition to the area of robust control
which also aims to con construct
controllers for various kinds of control
systems
but generally tends to limit itself to
very simple
usually linear policies about at which
it can prove guarantees
and particularly these guarantees
usually are stability guarantees i want
to stabilize my system
um sort of at all costs even in the
worst case scenario for that particular
system
and so both of these methods and both of
these ways of looking at things tend to
leave a little bit of
they tend to kind of leave various
desired attributes on the table
deep reinforcement learning can't make
any guarantees in general about
performance
but when you're operating something like
a power system where a critical mistake
means a blackout you can't
have that you need to have certain kinds
of performance performance guarantees
that are satisfied by your algorithm
at the same time robust control methods
which can give you those performance
guarantees tend to be really simple
and so you leave a lot of kind of actual
average case performance on the table
and so the goal of the this particular
project is to bridge the gap between
those two things
and so at a high level our approach is
basically to try to find a stabilizing
set
of actions that can be taken at any
moment and so
i'm just going to breeze through this
here but basically given some
uncertainty model of our underlying
system
and then a kind of lyapunov function you
can think of it as kind of a potential
function for your system
that you can obtain via robust control
the idea is that we basically find some
set of actions that is
safe and there are some equations on the
slide that describe what that means but
basically a set of actions that decrease
our lyapunov function
our potential function even in the worst
case under a system model
and then the basic idea is that we
say imagine we have the output of some
neural network that is proposing some
action that we take on this particular
system
can we project that output onto this set
of actions that we've derived that we
know are safe
and then if we can do that if we can
take the output of our neural network
if we can project it onto a safe set of
actions
and then train this whole thing end to
end then we can find a way basically to
optimize for performance while also
guaranteeing that the system will stay
stable
and so to kind of put this back again
into the neural network picture world
the the setup looks something like this
where you have your state
you have again a neural network with
some parameters your neural network is
proposing some initial
action that you might take onto the
system and then we project that action
onto the safe set of actions get our
final
action which is kind of provably
satisfying various kinds of safety
conditions on the system
and then we figure out how good that
action is and update the parameters of
the model accordingly
and what we see is is as follows so
in this plot the y-axis shows the sort
of time-integrated control
cost of various methods
the x-axis shows different methods that
we're testing out
so the first three methods here are
non-robust methods lqr which is a
control theory method
and a model based planner and proximal
policy optimization
both of which are reinforcement learning
methods so these are sort of non-robust
methods that we're testing
the fourth method here is a robust
control method
robust linear quadratic regulator
robust control method and then the last
two here are our our methods basically
robust variants of the two reinforcement
learning algorithms that are trained
using our method of just sort of
inserting this projection layer into the
last layer
and we're testing out two scenarios here
so the blue bars
show performance under sort of ordinary
conditions
basically the underlying system is
operating in a relatively normal
scenario
and then the blue bar here or sorry and
then the orange bar here
shows the performance of the system in
an adversarial
setting so here we actually have
designed a
model predictive controller based
adversary basically an adversary
that tries to create the worst possible
disturbance on
the system for every single method
and what we see is that under ordinary
operation so looking at the blue
bar our methods
outperform the kind of robust control
method
that said we don't we don't necessarily
outperform the main reinforcement
learning methods so in some sense the
kind of non-robust methods that are
optimized for average case performance
tend to do better than us in this sort
of average case scenario which is not
surprising
that said if you look at this
adversarial setting the orange bars
all of the robust methods including
hours stay stable
whereas the non-robust methods go
unstable so these actually breaks
in the in the bars these these bars
actually go much higher than the y-axis
shows and this is a log scale
but the basic idea is that all of the
non-robust methods go unstable and our
methods stay stable
so the idea is that by kind of inserting
this kind of
safe projection layer this projection
onto a safe set of actions
into the loop of the neural network we
can get improved average case
performance over robust control methods
while unlike non-robust methods actually
remaining stable in the system
so um that's actually all i have so the
sort of summary here is that
implicit layers can be a really powerful
tool for physical applications like
energy systems applications
um they can enable decision-driven
models for example the demand
forecasting model i showed that um
are well embedded into the systems in
which they're actually used
they can help provide inductive bias or
basically give some kind of notion of
the actual physics or
relationships that are held in the
underlying system so for example the
inverse optimal power flow application i
showed
and then they can also help enforce hard
constraints so for example in this
provably robust control method
where we were enforcing hard robustness
constraints of the underlying system via
deep learning
so with that i'm happy to take any
questions and thanks so much
thank you so much for the great talk
priya it was really great
let's go back to the the question by
greg
and he asked you probably have a access
to the chat room
he asked for any definition of task loss
is the optimization that includes the
task loss
always better than the optimization that
just accounts for accuracy
yeah so that's a that's a great question
so
i guess what i'll say is if you are able
to make a perfect prediction
then it doesn't matter what loss you use
if you make a perfect prediction you can
make perfect decisions on the basis of
that
absent that though i would say that
using a task loss is is a way to guess
more directly optimized for the metric
that you actually care about
there are various scenarios where if you
are example tuning the models
differently
or you're not training one of them
properly etcetera etcetera that
you could in theory have an accuracy
optimizing model that
um does uh worse or
sorry an accuracy optimizing model that
does better in a task-based setting than
a task-based model
i mean there are a lot of implementation
details that go into it but in theory
if you actually want to optimize the
task loss then
actually optimizing for the test slots
is is more likely to
to kind of yield that kind of result
okay any other questions
i have questions about the um you know
the 14 bus test cases model you
you sold for the second topic of your
talk um
it's relatively small uh problems right
uh realistic power systems um
there will be more buses i would imagine
um so it's natural to think about the
scalability
i guess um do you have any thought of
addressing that issue yeah it's a good
question
so um the for these kinds of
optimization layers
i guess there's sort of two um things
which is that is the
ac optimal power flow solver itself
going to scale and is the
differentiation through
the solver going to scale so the
question of is the ac optimal power
flow solver going to scale is certainly
of course one that is addressed in the
literature how do you get
how do you create solvers that you know
converge um when you're solving for
larger systems
that said i mean like there are existing
solvers that can
you know solve for for up to a few
thousand buses so we sort of can
leverage
existing innovations there and sort of
plug in the state-of-the-art solver that
you would like to use there
in the backwork pass all you really need
is the
um kind of the
jacobian of the kind of forward pass
solving procedure so so basically you
can kind of
the the backward pass does not get that
much more expensive to compute
even as the system gets larger because
you're fundamentally doing one
linear solve and one kind of matrix
inversion and if you can
explain sparsity in the structure and
all that all the better
um so we haven't tested it out on larger
systems yet but i'm kind of optimistic
that that it will scale
um the other kind of idea is that we did
a 14 best test system but we only use
200 data points and if you think about a
real world system you have you know
eight seven sixty data points a year if
you have hourly data
um and so in some sense i think the the
scale of the data that we tested on is
in some sense similar to the the scale
of the system that we tested on and i
would sort of expect that at least the
um
bidding results with scale up in at
least this kind of simulated setting
very good um i think this is a comment
rather than a
question from brenda and she think in
general it's easier to optimize the task
than the accuracy that is analogous of
discriminative versus generative
do you want to make any comment on that
no i mean i think yeah again like sort
of it all comes down to
what is your particular objective for
the particular problem and then what do
you want to do so
similarly lots of different choices that
people make in the context of
generative and discriminative that end
up mirroring that choice in this case as
well
absolutely okay next question by
rob when you use an implicit layer
do you enforce the implicit constraint
strongly or weakly
yeah it's a great question so we enforce
it
strongly the idea being that the
kind of in its purest form the
differentiation through the um
equilibrium conditions or fixed point
equations of that problem
only technically give you the correct
derivatives if you are
at the optimum of the problem this is
sort of it relies on the
implicit function theorem which
basically tells you about how you can
take derivatives at equilibrium
that said a lot of deep learning is
about making um you know
heuristic optimizations and
approximations for various tasks so
there are certainly some
folks who are looking at for example how
do you actually
compute a derivative that is reasonable
even in a scenario where you haven't
solved the
forward pass fully to convergence or
even if you have kind of on the on the
other side even if you have fully solved
the forward pass to convergence
um if the derivative is for some reason
difficult or expensive to compute for
example we were talking about discrete
problems earlier
can you use an approximation of the
derivative in the backward pass
um and still have that give you
reasonable results so definitely there's
sort of a lot of work being done in this
kind of how do you get this to still
work when you can't get both sides of
this to hold exactly
very nice okay any other questions
i have a question can i just say it
because i i was saying
yeah um thanks so much um
so i okay so yeah essentially your talk
has touched upon um complex optimization
as well as you know the
differentiability because i mean that's
how we
have to get the gradients to do the back
prep
um but have you thought about like so i
feel like
differentiability is probably more um
important
in that like otherwise you cannot like
backprop through things
um but have you guys thought about how
do you apply that to like non-complex
optimization type of problems so
something um that i'm kind of curious
about thanks
yeah that's a great question so um
honestly we haven't necessarily thought
about this completely generally
but in like a slightly ad-hoc manner so
for example this ac optimal power flow
top problem i was talking about is
non-convex
we definitely sort of figured out a way
to relax it iteratively solve it and
figure out a way in which we could use
a kind of convex final iterate and
differentiate through that instead
but that was sort of our way of creating
a differentiable version of this
non-convex optimization problem
there's also been some work in like
areas called like deep declarative
networks that use a kind of
differentiation through the lagrangian
in a way that i think
theoretically can accommodate non-convex
problems but
although i can't recall whether they
actually tried this out
um and then one thing to to try would
also be
um if you have a a solver um
and you are kind of um if you have kind
of a non-convex
optimization solver um that is iterative
and you sort of
solve it and you're solving some kinds
of fixed point equations to find the
final iterate
you can differentiate through those
final fixed point equations
now the challenge is with all of these
things you often don't have guarantees
about for example have i reached an
optimum in a non-convex solver and so
you're going to
you tend to suffer from the same issues
when then trying to come up with a
differentiable layer for that
um but definitely there are sort of
ways to do it that i think have to be
sort of adapted to the the context of
the individual non-convex problem
yeah but it's a great question and i
think a really difficult one
okay very nice any other question
hey priya i have uh i have a quick
non-technical question
are you guys doing another um uh
climate ai workshop at nurips this year
that's a great question thanks for
asking it gavin so yeah um
we are hoping to hold a couple of
different um climate change ai workshops
this upcoming year um
where for those who aren't as familiar
with this this venue basically
um a venue to sort of meet other people
and submit
and share work at the intersection of
climate change and machine learning
um with all of these workshops there's
always an application process to
after which the workshop organizer or
the conference organizers need to select
the workshop but we're definitely hoping
to
hold a couple of workshops at the the
upcoming major conferences so
the best way to find out about that is
to sign up for the climate change ai
newsletter which you can um
find on the on the climate change ai
website i can also drop the link into
the chat
um yeah so thanks for asking that great
yeah good luck hey wonderful
any any other questions
well i mean at the i mean we have a one
minute but um priya if you can
you know intro maybe advertise you know
your you know non-profit company um the
climate change ai
um in within like one or two minutes
that would be awesome
absolutely yeah so thank you for asking
so
um so climate change ai is uh basically
a volunteer initiative to
try to catalyze impactful work at the
intersection of climate change and
machine learning
and so basically we tend to hold kind of
workshops and other events to help
people meet others
who are working for example in machine
learning or climate relevant areas
and we also have some educational
resources on our website kind of
recordings of past
workshops and digital resources such as
a monthly newsletter and an online
discussion forum
and we also have a kind of a an ongoing
call for a grants program on climate
change and machine learning focused in
sub-saharan africa
and will be also making similar
hopefully exciting announcements
going forward regarding additional
infrastructure
and potentially funding programs so um
definitely if you're somebody who is
working in this area of climate change
and machine learning and or
or would like to kind of um and i'd like
to meet other people who are working in
this area i definitely encourage you to
check out our website
resources and and um various kinds of
events um
we also have a kind of uh every other
week a virtual happy hour
um kind of details on our website so
that's also something that if you're
interested in sort of meeting others in
this community in the short term that
you should feel free to check out
wonderful wonderful i mean you you are
doing
wonderful research and also as well as
wonderful
work for the uh the climate change
that's awesome
is there any other questions
if not uh let's thank priya for
wonderful talk
and her participants today be close
thank you so much for having me that was
fun all right and thanks everyone for
the great questions
awesome awesome i i hope you will get
connected with uh some
some folks at lawrence livermore and
continue the collaborations
absolutely okay thank you so much with
that uh we will uh at zone the meeting
today uh thank you so much for everyone
joining us